Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans ScienceClic,
les mathématiques de la relativité générale,
partie 4, métrique.
Notre modèle mathématique est de plus en
plus précis.
On a construit un système de coordonnées,
une grille qui repère la position des objets.
On a définit la notion de temps propre, pour
interpréter la ligne d’univers comme un
mouvement dans l’espace-temps.
Et on a obtenu une première équation fondamentale,
l’équation des géodésiques, qui prédit
la trajectoire des objets, à condition de
connaître les symboles de Christoffel.
Cependant, un problème persiste.
Nos coordonnées, bien qu’elles repèrent
des points, ne nous donnent aucune information
quant aux distances et aux angles réels qui
séparent les objets.
En effet, une case sur la grille ne représente
pas partout la même distance, ni la même
orientation, et il va falloir en tenir compte.
Pour ce faire, imaginons deux points sur la
feuille, très rapprochés l’un de l’autre.
A partir des coordonnées de ces deux points,
on désire exprimer la distance qui les sépare.
A première vue, on peut penser au théorème
de Pythagore.
En notant dx0 et dx1 les écarts de coordonnées
qui séparent les deux points, on aurait envie
que le carré de la distance, ds, est égal
à la somme des carrés des deux côtés.
Mais le théorème de Pythagore ne s’applique
que si les cases de la grille forment un repère
orthonormé.
Si les cases sont plus petites ou plus grandes,
ou que leurs axes ne sont pas orthogonaux,
le théorème de Pythagore ne fonctionne plus,
et il faut trouver une expression plus générale,
qui fonctionne quelle que soit la forme des
cases.
Dans le cas général, on peut montrer que
le carré de la distance peut toujours s’écrire
comme une somme de toutes les combinaisons
possibles de deux côtés multipliées par
des coefficients.
Ces coefficients dépendent directement de
la forme des cases.
Dans le cas précis où les cases sont des
carrés de côté 1, les coefficients valent
respectivement 1, 0, 0 et 1.
On retrouve alors le théorème de Pythagore.
Dans le cas général, on peut réunir les
composantes qui correspondent à chacun de
ces termes, dans un tableau, avec une ligne
et une colonne pour chaque coordonnée.
On appelle cet objet le tenseur métrique.
Sa représentation est un tableau dont les
composantes nous permettent de calculer des
petites distances.
Habituellement ce tableau est noté petit
g, et on numérote chacune de ces composantes
par les deux indices respectifs.
Dans le cas général on peut donc écrire
le carré de la distance qui sépare les deux
points comme la somme de chaque composante
du tableau, multipliée par les deux écarts
de coordonnées qui correspondent à ses deux
indices.
En utilisant cette formule, on peut notamment
exprimer la norme du vecteur vitesse.
Pour ce faire, on remplace les écarts de
coordonnées par les composantes du vecteur.
En se souvenant que la norme de la vitesse
est toujours égale à celle de la lumière,
on peut écrire une nouvelle version de cette
équation, plus précise.
Il est très important de comprendre que le
tenseur métrique est un outil fondamental
dans la théorie de la relativité générale.
En effet, pour le moment nous n’avions que
des coordonnées, des nombres abstraits, des
descriptions mathématiques, qui ne représentent
rien de fondamentalement concret.
Grâce au tenseur métrique, on peut transformer
ces descriptions abstraites en de vraies mesures
de distances et d’angles.
Le tenseur métrique est donc la clé qui
va nous permettre de relier les mathématiques
à la géométrie.
Pour finir, reprenons l’équation des géodésiques.
On a vu que cette équation prédit la trajectoire
d’un objet, à condition de connaître la
valeur des symboles de Christoffel.
Mais pour le moment, rien ne nous donnait
la valeur de ses symboles, et il était donc
impossible d’utiliser l’équation.
Il se trouve que ce tableau, le tenseur métrique,
va justement nous permettre de calculer les
symboles de Christoffel.
En effet, on a vu précédemment que les symboles
de Christoffel correspondent aux variations
des vecteurs de base le long des coordonnées.
Mais ces variations se traduisent directement
par un changement dans la forme des cases
sur la grille.
Et comme on l’a vu la forme des cases va
directement affecter les coefficients du tenseur
métrique.
En mesurant la variation du tenseur métrique
le long de la grille, on peut ainsi déterminer
les variations d’inclinaison des vecteurs
de base, et par conséquent les symboles de
Christoffel.
Grâce au tenseur métrique on va désormais
pouvoir exprimer la valeur des symboles, et
ainsi utiliser notre équation.
Lorsqu’on effectue ce calcul, qui prend
en compte la variation du tenseur métrique
pour exprimer les symboles de Christoffel,
on obtient une expression relativement complexe,
qui fait intervenir des dérivées du tenseur
métrique, car on l’a déplacé le long
des coordonnées, mais également son inverse,
que l’on note avec des indices en haut,
et qui est un autre tableau, complexe à calculer.
Cela dit, dans la majorité des cas, on peut
simplifier cette expression en choisissant
le bon système de coordonnées.
En l'occurrence on s’arrangera pour toujours
choisir une grille dont les axes sont perpendiculaires
entre eux.
Avec une telle grille, l’expression des
symboles de Christoffel se simplifie grandement.
Cette expression se calcule directement à
partir des composantes du tenseur métrique,
et en particulier nous n’avons plus besoin
de calculer son inverse.
A condition de connaître le tenseur métrique,
nous sommes désormais capable de calculer
les symboles de Christoffel, et en les injectant
dans l’équation des géodésiques, nous
sommes en mesure de prédire la trajectoire
des objets dans l’univers.
En somme, nous avons développé une méthode
qui décrit le mouvement d’un corps, en
fonction de la géométrie de l’espace-temps.
La géométrie de l’espace-temps est incarnée
par cet objet, le tenseur métrique, qui à
lui seul va décrire les rapports entre les
distances réelles et nos coordonnées.
Mais il nous manque une méthode pour pouvoir
déterminer cette géométrie, ce tenseur
métrique.
Dans les vidéos qui suivent nous allons voir
comment relier le tenseur métrique à la
courbure, et au contenu de l’espace-temps.
Comme d’habitude, résumons tous ces concepts
par un exemple concret.
Pour commencer, reprenons l’exemple de la
Terre, que l’on décrit par les coordonnées
de latitude et longitude.
A la surface d’une sphère, par rapport
à cette grille, le tenseur métrique peut
s’exprimer comme le tableau suivant.
La lettre R désigne le rayon de la planète,
et les angles theta et phi correspondent aux
coordonnées de latitude et longitude.
Cette expression générale va nous permettre
de calculer le tenseur métrique en n’importe
quel point de la sphère.
Quel que soit l’emplacement où l’on souhaite
le calculer, il suffit de remplacer theta
par la latitude du point.
Si l’on souhaite mesurer des petites distances
autour de ce point, on a vu précédemment
qu’il suffit d’additionner chaque composante
du tableau, multipliée par les écarts de
coordonnées.
En calculant cette somme, on obtient la valeur
de ds carré, qui correspond au carré de
la distance qui sépare les deux points.
Cela dit, le tenseur métrique ne nous donne
accès qu’à de très petites distances.
Si l’on souhaite mesurer des grandes distances,
il va falloir le calculer à plusieurs endroits,
car la forme des cases peut évoluer le long
du trajet que l’on souhaite mesurer.
En termes mathématiques cela se traduit par
une intégrale, c’est à dire une somme
sur une infinité de petites distances.
Le tenseur métrique est un outil extrêmement
puissant.
A partir de descriptions abstraites, des coordonnées,
il va nous permettre de mesurer des vraies
distances, concrètes, à la surface de la
sphère.
Pour finir, nous allons pouvoir appliquer
toutes ces notions géométriques à un espace-temps.
Prenons l’exemple le plus simple d’un
espace-temps vide dans lequel se déplace
un objet.
Par exemple imaginons qu’un satellite se
soit perdu dans le vide de l’espace.
Pour décrire sa trajectoire, nous allons
munir notre espace-temps de deux coordonnées.
Une coordonnée de temps, t, qui mesure le
temps sur notre horloge, et une coordonnée
d’espace, x, qui mesure la position du satellite
le long d’un axe.
Au fil de son temps propre, le satellite va
pouvoir se déplacer à travers les deux coordonnées.
Dans un tel espace-temps, vide, le tenseur
métrique prend la forme suivante.
Ce tenseur métrique est relativement simple,
d’autant plus qu’il ne dépend pas des
coordonnées, c’est à dire qu’il est
le même partout sur la grille.
En particulier, comme il ne varie pas sur
la grille, toutes ses dérivées sont nulles,
et tous les symboles de Christoffel valent
donc 0.
En les injectant dans l’équation des géodésiques,
on obtient simplement que les composantes
de la vitesse du satellite ne varient pas.
Le satellite va se déplacer de façon constante
à travers nos coordonnées.
Cette métrique relativement simple, qui décrit
le mouvement des objets dans un espace-temps
vide, est ce qu’on appelle la métrique
de Minkowski.
La métrique de Minkowski correspond à l’espace-temps
de la relativité restreinte.
Elle est plutôt simple du fait qu’elle
ne dépend pas des coordonnées.
L’espace-temps possède la même géométrie
partout sur la grille.
Un premier résultat que l’on peut obtenir
à partir de la métrique de Minkowski est
le phénomène de dilatation du temps.
Pour ce faire, nous avons obtenu précédemment
une équation qui reliait la norme de la vitesse
à ses composantes.
En utilisant cette équation dans le cadre
du satellite, nous allons pouvoir exprimer
sa vitesse temporelle en fonction de sa vitesse
spatiale.
L’expression qu’on obtient est d'autant
plus grande que le satellite se déplace vite
dans l’espace.
Cela signifie que plus le satellite se déplace
rapidement dans l’espace, plus notre temps
va s’écouler rapidement par rapport à
son temps propre.
En somme, plus un objet se déplace vite dans
l’espace, plus son temps propre va ralentir
par rapport à notre temps.
A première vue, la métrique de Minkowski
peut paraître banale, plutôt simple.
Mais il ne faut pas s’y méprendre.
La métrique de Minkowski est très particulière
en cela qu’elle contient un moins 1.
Ce moins 1 est une propriété étrange et
fondamentale de notre univers.
Il nous signifie que les dimensions d’espace
et de temps sont fondamentalement opposées.
Reprenons notre satellite et mesurons la distance
qui le sépare d’un point dans son futur.
Ici par exemple cette distance est de 2 secondes
lumière.
Si l’on décale ce point, dans l’espace,
on pourrait s’attendre à une distance plus
grande, mais à cause de ce moins 1 dans la
métrique, la distance est en réalité plus
petite.
Et plus le point est décalé dans l’espace,
plus cette distance diminue.
Lorsque le point est incliné en diagonale
par rapport au satellite, c’est à dire
qu’il parcourt autant de temps que d’espace,
la distance qui sépare le satellite du point
est étrangement de 0.
Un objet se déplaçant le long de cette diagonale
ne parcourerait en réalité aucune distance
dans l’espace-temps, et son temps propre,
c’est à dire la graduation sur sa trajectoire,
ne s’écoulerait pas.
C’est ce qu’on appelle plus communément
la lumière.
Au delà de cette diagonale, les distances
deviennent des racines carrées de nombres
négatifs, ce sont des nombres imaginaires,
et le satellite ne pourra jamais atteindre
de tels points.
La lumière est infranchissable.